If you want to add email functionality to your application, this is the course.
Craig Dennis has created some of our most popular courses and he's back to teach this course.
He's going to start all the way back at the invention of email and
by the end you will know how to make your app send emails using multiple programming languages and libraries.
(bright music)
- Hey there.
I'm Craig and I'm a developer.
I'm assuming that you're
here because you want to add
or you've been asked to
add email functionality
to an application that you're working on.
This is one of those things
where you're like, of course,
adding email functionality
makes a ton of sense.
Oh wait, how do I do that?
Maybe you got asked to send
a confirmation email when
someone buys something on your site.
This is called transactional email,
or maybe you're trying to
personalize your marketing emails
with actual user data from the database.
Email provides the ability to
track how receivers interact
with your message, which opens
up a very powerful analytics
solution that you can use
to help guide your business.
Now, any way you look at it,
email is an important part
of the applications that
we build, so understanding
how it works as well as
what its limitations are
will greatly help you
throughout your career.
Everyone uses email.
Email's one of those things
that we developers often take
for granted and as you're
about to see, there is a lot
that goes into making it work properly.
In fact, a popular saying is this,
sending email successfully
is more art than science.
In this course, we're gonna
take a deep dive into email.
We'll take a look at both
the art and the science.
Now I'm gonna do my best
to make this course fun and interesting.
Now, I'll start off by showing
a little bit of its history.
I think the only way to truly
understand its current state
is to take a quick stroll
through its evolution as a technology.
There's also quite a bit
of drama in the past,
so if you're into that sort of thing,
it's gonna get a little juicy.
The email world comes with
a smattering of acronyms.
Now, you and I both know
that those letters can make
you feel overwhelmed AF,
my kids use that.
I think it stands for
absolutely frustrating
and well, I don't like feeling overwhelmed
and y'all don't either, right?
Where'd everybody go?
I guess that return
to office email ended
up in the spam folder.
This course isn't going
to be very code heavy.
I'll show you some code examples
and I'll point you where
to learn more about
what you find particularly interesting.
We'll also take a look at
some suggested approaches
and peruse our way
through some email APIs.
I'll also explain what that
means if that's new to you.
Throughout this course, I'm going to refer
to the notes, they're
attached to this video
and I will point you
in that direction when
there's more to learn.
I'd love for you to get in the habit
of checking things out there.
I'll document in there anything
that's different from my
right now to your right now.
Basically, it's gonna be a
pretty great resource for you
during and after this course.
Sound good?
Okay, so to kick things
off, I'd like for you
to try and imagine a time
before email even existed,
Like all great inventions.
It's hard to imagine a time
before that invention was created, like
how did we even survive without it?
Email is definitely one of those, right?
I mean, how did we
communicate before that?
Did we just call each other?
Well, it turns out, yeah,
we did do that quite a bit.
There were lots and lots of phone calls.
In the office world,
there was this concept
called inter-office mail
and you would send physical
documents in large envelopes
to specific coworkers in the office.
There was a whole mail
room and a delivery system
and they would manually
deliver these documents
to employees inboxes, which
were actually physical boxes
that you put mail in, in-box.
Oftentimes, your job as an employee was
to sign off on the
document that you received
and then forward it on
along to the next person.
Some documents even required signatures
and if you needed to keep a copy,
there was a technology called carbon copy
where you would write through the page
and it would appear on the attached page.
Of course, that carbon copy initials are
CC, pretty cool, right?
So you can imagine that's what happened.
Someone took this already
working interoffice mail system
and digitized it or
made it more electronic.
Electronic mail, if you will,
email for short, there is
actually a patent filed
for the concept of email
as we know it, and it was created
by, are you ready for this?
A 14-year-old boy at MIT,
his name was Shiva Ayyadurai
and it's super impressive at
how many concepts his project introduced
that are still with us today.
He wanted to create a
system that anyone could use
and I'd say he succeeded.
I mean, my grandfather
had an email address.
Now, one of the reasons that
you might not have heard
of this 14-year-old before
is because of some drama.
There's so conflicting opinion on
what an email actually means.
Let's go back a little bit before 1978
when this program was conceived,
remember this was before the home
computer was readily available.
So many programmers spent
their time using a mainframe.
Think of it kind of like
the cloud, a shared computer
that somewhere else
would execute your code.
It became necessary to
communicate with other users
of the system, so there was a bit
of a super early instant
messaging going on.
They send a message,
- Hey there dude, I need
to get some cycles on the
the mainframe, you dig.
- And the other programmer
would respond with, go for it.
I just wrapped up check
you on the flip side.
I'm not sure how they spoke,
but I'd imagine it was
something like this
without emojis or anything.
Those messages worked great,
but they only functioned while
both parties were online,
so a way to capture messages into a place
that the party could pick up later
when they logged in was created.
Arpanet is known as the predecessor
to the internet that we all know and love.
It consisted of a series of machines
that were connected
together through a network.
A software developer named
Ray Tomlinson created a way
to send a message to
other connected computers.
He called it SNDMSG or send message if
you put the missing letters back in.
The way he did this was
by using the at sign
to separate the user from the computer.
Tomlinson is often noted as
the grandfather of the email
because of this cross
computer messaging system
and very specifically for
making use of that at sign,
what was that symbol even used for before?
Who knows?
Here's where the drama comes in.
Now, oftentimes Tomlinson is credited
as the creator even though
as we heard the 14-year-old Shiva created
and patented the concept
and as we can see added more
of the familiar interoffice
parallels to our email world
as we know it now, Shiva and
Ray have had a lifelong beef
and I'll put more in the
notes for those of you
who are into that sort of thing.
I can think of one fantastic
way of saying this.
- I think that my new
husband, Dr. Shiva Ayyadora
the inventor of email.
- That was television's own Fran Drescher.
She was married to Shiva for a little bit
and she definitely
convinced me the popularity
and rapid adoption
of the email esque application
on Arpanet is argued
to have laid the path for
the creation of the internet.
What it definitely did was
start another beef one that is
so big it has its own
Wikipedia page called.
- [Announcer] The Protocol Wars.
- And while fascinating as well.
I'll leave that to you to
dig into on your own time.
Let's take a look at the winners of
that war here in just a bit.
As we know that at sign
was super important,
it's almost like a rite of
passage to using the internet
and I'm sure we can all remember
our first email address.
Mine was very ominous
sounding, Craig2000@aol.com.
What was yours?
Let me know in the comments.
Let's take a quick break and
let all that history seep in,
but when we come back,
let's take a look at how
that important at sign works
today in the modern internet.
(bright music)
An email address contains two parts.
On the left side of that infamous
at symbol is the username
and on the right side is the domain name.
Now, the way the email finds
its way to you is by making use
of that domain name portion.
The way it's able to do that is with DNS
or domain name system.
Servers that are on the
internet have an IP address.
IP stands for internet protocol.
Now, we'll dive into
protocols here in a bit.
An IP address traditionally
is four numbers between one
and 255 separated by periods.
The web browser uses DNS
to find the web server
that hosts the webpage that
you're attempting to view.
That URL contains the domain name
of the place that you're looking at.
A common analogy that's
used to explain this
is a little dated for
years we've been teaching.
It's like, you know,
it's like the phone book.
You know you look up the name
and then you get the phone number,
but when was the last time you ever
even used the phone book?
Let's try this one on for size.
You can search for a restaurant
in your maps application
and it returns the latitude
and longitude for you as well
as turn by turn directions.
It translates the name of
the place that you're looking
for into map coordinates.
DNS does a similar sort of thing.
It uses the domain name
to look up the IP address
of the server you're requesting.
The way this works is that the owners
of a domain must create DNS records
that associate their domain name
with the server's IP addresses,
and I say servers here
because there can be multiple
and we've been talking about web servers,
but there's also email
servers, so what happens is
that the domain owners add
what is known as an MX record,
a mail exchange record or records.
Actually, you can have multiple MX records
and you can prioritize them
so that they get checked
for the user in order.
Now, a thing to remember is
that these early days,
websites were not full-blown
applications like we have these days.
These sites were just kind of
like informational billboards.
They were definitely a far
way away from the concept
of a web-based email program like Gmail.
Now, what these early
email adopters were using
were called email clients.
They were actual applications
that ran on your computer
and they're still around today.
What you, the user of the
email client would do was
to configure your domain and
then you could use it to send
and receive messages.
In early cases, messages were
downloaded to your computer
and stored there locally, which of course,
caused problems later when
you got a new computer,
but we weren't there yet.
We were here.
You've got mail.
AOL would send an actual
CD ROM in the mail
and you'd install it and
it included a mail client
and we were so, so
excited about being able
to communicate with each other.
These clients would use the domain name
to find the mail exchanger, but then what?
Great question, and I'm
glad you asked, it's time
that we dive a little bit into the winners
of the Protocol Wars.
A protocol is a set of agreed upon rules
and they aren't just
limited to technology.
We have them in real life too.
For instance, if we are meeting each other
for the first time and I stick
out my hand, the protocol
that us humans have established is
that you would put your hand in mine
and we would make a tight squeeze
and we would move it up and down, right?
A handshake.
It's kind of weird when
you think about it,
but a protocol nonetheless.
Now, it'd be really strange
if I put my hand out for you
to shake it and then you
did the chicken dance.
I mean, I'd probably
appreciate you doing that,
but you'll for sure be
breaking, breaking the protocol
that we have unspoken set up.
Here, let's do another one.
How about the way
that we send actual mail
like through the post office?
Now, the protocol as I
understand it is this.
I put the contents in an envelope
and on that envelope I
write your name and address
and I also put my return
contact info in the corner.
I put a stamp, I drop this in the mailbox
and some post office hero
comes and picks it up.
It finds its way to you.
You get it and you're like,
oh, hey, this is for me
and oh look, it's from Craig.
I wonder what it is.
We just successfully ran a real life
mail protocol, snail mail,
though it's not what
we're here to talk about.
What we're here to talk about is the
electronic version of that.
How did we possibly
enable everyone to be able
to start sending emails?
Any guesses?
If you guessed a well-defined
protocol, you got it.
As the internet that we know
and love was being conceived,
it became clear that in order
to make it open and
extensible, it was going
to need some standards
and the way that these
standards came into being was
by some pretty clever group brainstorming,
a memorandum called an RFC
or a request for comment was created
and that had a proposal
and it was discussed by a group
of people interested in building a stable
and secure internet.
This group that I'm talking
about specifically here
is the IETF, the Internet
Engineering Task Force,
which I think sounds like
a group of superheroes
and I guess in reality, they truly are.
I know I owe my career
and most of my knowledge
to their early enablement of these ideas.
There are multiple of
these superhero groups,
the internet cinematic
universe, if you will,
that weigh in on these RFCs and
after they're approved, they become known
as internet standards.
Now, this RFC process brought us some
of the greatest hits, we're
hanging out in one right now.
Check out your browser's address bar.
The address starts with HTTP.
That's hypertext transfer protocol
and it was introduced as an RFC
and it became an internet standard,
and these are pretty detailed
and I find them quite fascinating.
I love learning this history,
but I know that's not why you're here.
Check the notes if I just nerd sniped you,
so the internet standard that I'd love
to dive into here is an
early hit, number 10, the one
that enabled us to send email.
SMTP or Simple Mail Transfer Protocol.
You might not agree that
it is exactly simple,
but it is the defacto way to
get your mail transferred.
Now, conceptually, you have
a sender and a receiver.
They introduce themselves
and do a handshake, oh hey, just like us.
It's a plain text protocol,
which means you can kind
of read it with a little more information
that there's a set of SMTP commands
and status codes that could
come back in response.
They help you build the envelope
and explain what it is that you're trying
to send and to whom.
If you're feeling brave, you
can actually make use of this
through a tool like Telnet,
which will allow you
to communicate with a remote server.
SMTP is the internet standard
used on the sending side,
but there are also protocols
that allow mail clients
to retrieve the email from
their mail server, POP,
or post office protocol
often now called POP 3,
which is the current version,
helps you as a reader
of the email receive a copy
of it from your server side mailbox.
These days, it's hard to imagine,
but there was actually a
time when we weren't always
able to be online.
Now, this protocol enables you
to download messages from your mail
server to your local mailbox.
You wanted this so that you could deal
with them when you were offline.
Now, original attempts here
actually remove the message
from the mail server
after it was downloaded
to the user's client site application.
Nowadays, this can cause some issues
because we access our
email from multiple devices
and things can get outta
sync, which leads us to IMAP
or the internet message access protocol.
This allows for better synchronization
and internal messaging,
and while you probably aren't here
to learn about the
receiving side of things,
you will see both POP and IMAP
quite a bit in this space.
Now, I don't want you to
feel like you need to be able
to explain how these work
without looking 'em up,
but I do want you to recognize
them when you see them.
You'll encounter these in documentation
and now you should have a basic
understanding of what they are.
Remember, if you ever want
a refresher, check the notes
for more info.
So now we have all these
wonderful programs.
Anyone who implements the SMTP
protocol can send a message.
You can actually even do this
dance from the command line on
your computer or directly from code,
and then of course the reason
we can't have nice things,
the bad actors showed up.
You guessed it.
It's time to talk about
spamming and spoofing.
Earlier when I asked you
to drop your first email
address into the comments,
I bet you had a weird
feeling about doing that.
Something along the lines
of, if I put this in here,
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get
so many emails that I don't want.
Now, as you know, we call
those emails the ones
that you don't want, spam.
Why would we do this?
Who wouldn't want this
delicious stuff, right?
Even though this feels like some sort
of advanced prop dad joke, the
term that we use for emails
that we don't want is actually
rooted in this meat in a can.
Well, sort of.
The British comedy troupe Monty Python
had a bunch of famous sketches
and one of their most absurd
involves a person attempting
to order a meal and they noticed
that everything on the
menu had spam in it,
and that person asks.
- Have got anything without spam in it?
Well, a spam egg, sausage
and spam, it's not got much spam in it.
- And asks.
- Why can't you have egg,
bacon and spam and sausage?
- That's got spam in it.
- It's not as much as
spam egg sausage and spam.
- Look, could I have egg, bacon, spam
and sausage without the spam?
- Because everything has spam,
spam and more spam.
Eventually, Vikings show
up and chaos ensues.
And chaos did ensue on
the email front too.
Spam was everywhere.
Those well-defined
protocols worked really,
really well at connecting people
and bad actors as we
call them now, saw this
as an opportunity to communicate
what they were selling
and our inboxes were just
bombarded with offers
for quite literally everything.
There were email lists that were for sale
and oh boy, if you got
on one of those lists,
you got so much spam.
Those lists are still for sale
by the way, don't buy them.
It might sound like a good idea,
but it is a very, very bad idea,
but in the beginning,
it's important to remember
that there were no real standards
or even etiquette at the time,
so everyone was probably a little guilty
of over sending messages that
receivers didn't really want.
There were all sorts of lawsuits,
people actually got arrested.
Check the notes for more.
There's so much drama, right?
Finally in 2003, the FTC got involved
and get this, the act is
called Controlling the Assault
of Non-Solicited Pornography and Marketing
or CAN SPAM for short.
I see what you did there FTC.
Now this act applies
to all commercial email
messages, not just bulk ones.
The non-compliant penalties
can be pretty hefty,
up to $50,000.
These introduced some rules
that are pretty straightforward
and really made a difference in the amount
of spam that we were fighting.
Let's talk through them really quick.
Don't use false or misleading
header information.
Now all of the information on
your email envelope must be
accurate and identify the person
or business as the sender.
Don't use deceptive subject lines.
Be careful with the click bait.
You have to make sure that
your messages is about
what the subject claims.
Identify the message as an ad.
You need to let people know
that you're sending an ad.
There are best practices here
and there's more in the notes.
Tell recipients where you're located.
You have to provide a
valid street address.
Tell recipients how
to opt out a receiving future
marketing email from you.
You have to let your users tell you
that they don't want any more messages
like the one that you just sent.
You need to do this, again,
best practices are in the notes.
Remember that subscribers
and members can opt out
of marketing emails too.
If you have an app that
makes use of subscriptions
and memberships, you
have to also make sure
that they can opt out.
Now, this one can be a little tricky,
but don't forget to let
them not receive the emails.
And honor opt-out request promptly.
This can get a little tricky too.
If you offer opt-out,
it has to work for at least 30 days
and you have to honor it
within a minimum of 10 days.
Monitor what others are
doing on your behalf.
The law makes clear that even
if you hire another company
to handle your email marketing,
you can't contract away
your legal responsibility
to comply with the law.
The CAN SPAM Act made a huge
dent in the emails being sent,
but spam still maintained
a very impressive sometimes
upwards of 70% of all email traffic.
Now, luckily for those of
us with email addresses,
the spam percentage is
constantly dropping.
Our email providers are making it harder
and harder for the bad actors
to get those bad emails
to land in your inbox.
Can you do me a favor?
I want you to go and
look at your spam folder.
Just take a quick look in there.
Go ahead and pause me and then
take a peek and then come back to me.
Pretty gross right?
Now however, did you see in there
there's probably some messages
that were incorrectly marked spam.
Providers have done
the best that they can,
but sometimes wanted messages
actually end up in there.
As someone who is considering
getting email running
for your application, you don't
want this to happen to you.
Well talk through some best
practices through the rest
of this course of how to get
your message into the inbox
and out of the spam folder.
This is called deliverability
and it is truly an art form.
Now, one of the first
points in the CAN SPAM Act
talks about not faking the sender.
Unfortunately, SMTP doesn't
provide authentication,
so it's relatively easy to
pretend to be someone else.
If we flip back to our snail mail example,
I can swap out my return
address to whatever I want
and maybe that'd make you wanna open it.
Well, I could do the same
thing with my email envelope.
Pretending to be someone you
are not is called spoofing
and it's a bummer.
The good news is there
are ways of handling this
and employing suggested
methods will greatly help you
with your deliverability journey.
Let's take a quick break
and when we come back,
let's take a look at some
of these authentication mechanisms.
Mm.
(peaceful music)
(water whooshing)
As you can imagine, it's
important to the receivers
of your emails that they can identify
that the emails actually from you.
As more and more spoofing
happened, technology was added
to give you a little more power
in making this dream happen.
For many years, these
techniques were known
as a best practice.
These days, however, they're basically
slowly becoming required.
Changes are happening in 2024
that will make all senders start sending
properly authenticated emails
to be considered trustworthy.
The way this works is with surprise,
a group of more acronyms.
I apologize.
I know that there's a lot in this space.
Now, I want you to approach
these the same way.
I don't want you to feel like you have
to understand them completely,
but it will certainly benefit you
to be able to recognize them.
You'll find these acronyms
and blogs and dropdown menus
and function parameters
often without any explanation
whatsoever, and yes, I realize
that the more pedantically
focused learners may say
that these are actually
initialisms and non acronyms,
but I say any initialism
can be an acronym.
If you try hard enough.
SPF or SPF stands for
Sender Policy Framework.
It can be set up by
adding an additional DNS
record for your mail server.
This specifies who can send messages down
to a specific IP address.
This makes it way more
challenging for spoofers to try
and manipulate your envelope.
DKIM or Domain Keys Identified
Mail is similar to SPF.
You publish your public
key as a DNS record,
but DKIM adds an additional layer.
You sign each and every message.
The receiver can use the
signature to validate
that the message has
not been tampered with.
Most mail clients provide a way for you
to see the original
message as it was sent.
For instance, in Gmail, I can
open up the additional menu
and choose show original.
Here you can see if the SPF check passed
and also what happened with the DKIM
and if you want to dig,
you can peep at all
the headers that came across.
DMARC or domain based message
authentication reporting
and conformance came on the scene in 2015
and it moves to further
take on spoofing issues.
It extends both SPF
and DKIM to allow the
receiving email server
to authenticate the incoming message.
A DNS DMARC record is added
and in it it defines how you would like
to handle any message that
didn't meet the specification.
It can also specify how
strict things need to be.
Email domain owners can
get a daily report of
what messages failed to pass.
More in the notes on DMARC,
again coming very soon,
everyone will need to adhere
to these to be able to send
to Gmail and Yahoo.
Now, the advice is that
every other provider is going
to follow their lead, so make
sure that you check the notes
for how to embrace these email
authentication protocols.
You are now armed with
the foundational knowledge
that you need to start sending emails.
There is a lot
that goes into making your
email adventure successful,
and I'm so glad that you've
dipped your toes in its history,
the terminology and the challenges.
You have a pretty firm handle
now on the what and the why.
In the remainder of this course,
we are gonna focus on the how.
Now, remember this how
includes both science and art.
We are gonna focus a
little bit heavier now
on the science portion,
but keep at the top
of your mind as we talk through things.
I want you to have excellent
email deliverability.
I want you hanging out in the inbox
and avoiding the spam folder.
Otherwise, what's it all for?
There's a best practice surrounding email
deliverability that I love.
Always ask yourself this, am
I sending the right message
to the right person at the right time
with the right frequency?
Now, this question applies both
to the transactional emails
that you send as well as
the marketing messages
that you might be considering.
You are essentially building a reputation
and you wanna make sure
that you make a great first
and long lasting
impression with your users
and the email providers.
All right, let's check out some code.
I've got great news for
you. You are not alone.
As is the case in most things
that you'll find along
your coding journey.
Someone has been here before
and if you're lucky, they've already
written most of the code for you.
Email is pretty awesome for this actually,
there's so much email code
written for you already
that it's almost hard to choose.
These packaged up code bundles
are typically called libraries.
Someone has already taken the time
to follow those email
protocols that we talked about
and it's been all abstracted away for you.
Python embraces a batteries
included approach,
which means there's a
module included for email.
You'll see here that you
can create an email message
and then send it using
the SMTP live module.
Good thing you've heard about the simple
mail transfer protocol, right?
One thing to point out here is
that you can also use an SMTP command
to encrypt your emails.
It's called start TLS or startles
if you're feeling cute, I've
dropped the information in the
notes about how to use TLS.
If you don't have access
to an SMTP server,
check out the notes for some ideas on how
to get your hands on some.
Thanks to those well-defined
internet standards,
you can pretty much guarantee
that every programming language is going
to have something similar.
Check the notes for some guidance on how
to find examples in your language.
It'll probably help you to imagine
how you might end up using
this in your day-to-day
coding journey, most applications
that have users authenticate
have some pretty
common workflows.
For example, there's almost always a flow
to handle when a user
forgets their password.
Typically, what you do here is
ask the user for their email.
You check that it exists in your system,
and if it does, you send an email
with a password reset link.
You can imagine how you
might do that right?
In your controller, you check
the submitted email address
to verify and then you'd
craft an email message
and send it using your library.
It's pretty critical
that this specific email
makes it to your user quickly.
You don't want this email to
end up in the spam folder.
They'll be expecting it,
and if they don't get it,
they're probably going
to quickly give up on whatever
it was that they were trying
to accomplish in your application,
and we don't even really need
to imagine the overarching business
not having users being able
to log into your system
is well, bad for business.
While this inline solution will work,
it's probably a good
idea to get involved with
how your marketing messages
are being sent out.
The IP address that you send messages from
has its own reputation.
A best practice worth exploring
is to keep the senders
that you use for transactional messaging
separate from your marketing senders.
It's also not a great idea
to just start sending a bunch
of emails all at once as
that could introduce some suspicion.
It's best to take some time
and build up your reputation
before sending bulk messages.
This is called IP warmup.
Remember that the email
providers are doing their best
to stop spam before it
reaches their customers.
You need to make sure that they trust you.
There is a lot that goes into
this email deliverability
and there are entire companies
who make it their business
to make this happen for you.
Let's take a quick break
and then let's take a look
at some email API services.
(peaceful music)
Application programming interfaces
or APIs provide the
applications that you build
with new functionality.
They abstract away complexity
and give you a straightforward way
to achieve the impossible.
Now, if APIs are new to
you, check the notes.
I have a whole course on them
specifically for beginners.
Sometimes a challenge is so big
that an entire company forms
around the problem and it provides an API
to help us developers
solve those problems.
Email is one of those
challenging problems.
Not only is the landscape
complex, but it's ever evolving.
You definitely will benefit
from having an entire team
of people focus on your solution.
There are multiple email APIs
and each one of them have their
own strengths and weaknesses.
One of my favorite ways
to find new products is
to use GitHub Awesome lists.
There are tons of lists
of solutions out there
and folks maintain those lists.
So here's the one for emails.
Now, traditionally, when
presented with these options,
I've always chosen syngrid
when my current employer Twilio
and Syngrid merged, it
was a pleasant surprise
and I'm so stoked that
we have an email channel
for all of our applications.
My appreciation for the
work they do has only gotten
stronger, but everyone's
needs are different,
so please don't just take my
word for it, peruse around
and see what resonates well with you.
There's something for everyone.
It might turn out that you don't even want
to choose an email API,
and you wanna roll your
own code like we just saw.
I do recommend taking the
time to familiarize yourself
with the offerings that
are available to you.
They can inspire you with ideas
that you might not have
come up with before.
And remember, API companies
always get better.
There are teams of people making sure
that you get the most up-to-date security,
and they assist you in following
the ever-changing best
practices, all those acronyms
and new protocols that might crop up,
they've got their eyes on them.
There will be reporting and monitoring.
You can pretty much guarantee
that due to the beauty
of competition, the
service is going to try
and be the best, so you're always going
to be getting new features.
Now, most likely, they'll
guide you through how
to do the more detailed DNS things.
I don't know about you, but DNS
record manipulation for some
of the bigger companies that I've worked
for is not something that
I've been allowed to touch.
They don't want me in
there and I totally get it.
No offense.
Some of these email APIs
prepare the requests
that you need to make and email them
to your system administrator.
I can't tell you how much
I appreciate this feature.
Good email APIs will provide ways for you
to separate your transactional
and marketing messages
and guide you there as a best practice.
While you now know that's
why that's important,
it might not have been clear
to those just getting started.
Some companies even have
deliverability experts
that will work with you if you're having
trouble deciding on which to choose.
Check out their blogs.
Are they publishing the information
that will help you in the
art portion of emails?
Do they have the science in
place to meet your needs?
A feature that you'll want to take
a close look at is templating.
We haven't really chatted about this yet,
but you can use HTML
in your email messages.
This really helps with design,
but producing an email that looks good
and works on all those
clients, it's really tricky.
The HTML that you can use is limited
and it has a lot of gotchas,
especially in those
client side applications.
Now, a good email API will
offer you a way to edit
and create beautiful emails.
Most of these providers
allow for some sort of way
to maintain a list of your contacts.
Remember, the more engaged
your contacts get, the better.
Keeping well-maintained
contact lists really
helps to ensure this.
Also, you'll probably want
to have some help dealing
with unsubscribes.
Remember those rules of the CAN SPAM.
A good email API will help
you adhere to those rules
and help you stop from making mistakes.
It's in the company's best interest
and yours to keep your reputation healthy.
They want you to be able to scale
to send millions of emails.
Let them help you.
One of my favorite
analogies about using an API is to think
of it about like a package delivery system
like FedEx or UPS.
You could of course get in
your car with your package
and drive over to deliver it in person,
and if the person doesn't
answer the doorbell,
you probably don't wanna
just leave it there.
Maybe you'll come back
later or give them a call.
Maybe they want you to deliver
it to their office actually.
Now, eventually you're
gonna get the package there,
but probably not something
you wanna do all the time.
I mean, especially if you
have lots of packages,
you probably wanna use something
more like a package delivery
service like a UPS or a FedEx.
You know that they're the experts
and they have ways of getting your package
there no matter what.
They have worked through the
workflows and are reliable.
In fact, they'll even send status updates
as your package is en
route to that destination.
Oh, if you don't mind me
popping outta that analogy,
let's talk about how rich
the events that happen are
when you send an email.
When an email gets sent,
there is information that is
most likely made available
to you via your email API of choice.
Now, a common approach to
this is to use webhooks.
Webhooks are like a reverse API.
Instead of you calling the API.
The API calls you when the event occurs.
Now you write code that handles it.
Email has so many great
events that you can use
to improve your deliverability
and your engagement.
You'll see here these delivery
events like process, dropped,
delivered, deferred and bounced.
They're super handy in
building reporting tools.
You also have super
powerful engagement events
like open and click.
This information here shows who they are
and even what they clicked.
Now, this can be super
helpful if you're trying
to attract a certain audience.
There's all sorts of excellent information
that you can process and if
your service provides it,
you can actually see when
people report your email as spam
or if they choose to unsubscribe.
Now, most likely, your
service provides a way
to manage this, but these
can be additionally helpful.
I love seeing what people
build with these events.
It really helps you to build healthy
and reputable email campaigns.
Now, take a moment and think about
how this might benefit you
in whatever brought you
to this course in the first place.
Would it be helpful to track your
transactional message delivery?
What about if you're thinking about
sending marketing emails?
Wouldn't it be awesome to be able
to track which message
is landing the best?
You could test out all sorts of things.
You could probably use this
data to answer the question,
am I sending the right message
to the right person at the right time
with the right frequency?
Now, while I got your brain activated,
let's take things one step further.
So not only can you write
code to handle the events
that happen when you send a message, some
of these email APIs
actually let you process
incoming messages.
I've seen some super cool
stuff built with this idea.
One of my favorite implementations
that I can think of
of all time is Expensify.
I can email a photo of a
receipt into Expensify.
It receives my message,
processes the photo using OCR
or Optical Character Resolution,
and because it knows who I
am from my email address,
it can create an expense report
in a draft state filled out
with my expense item.
They send me back a message
with a link to the report.
It's beautiful.
I think with the approachability
of AI these days,
we are going to see more
and more of these inbound
email-based applications.
Now, I know it's outta
the scope of this course,
but I just wanted to share
my enthusiasm for it.
Check the notes for more
information on this concept.
You did it.
You made it to the end of the course.
I hope you had a fun time and
learned a lot about the art
and science necessary to
make email work for you.
This is a journey
and I can tell you already
you're off to a great start.
Please keep me posted on your progress.
I take your feedback very seriously
and I'd love to hear from you.
Please check the notes for
how to get in touch with me.
Thanks so much for hanging out,
and we'll see you real soon.
(upbeat music begins)
(upbeat music continues)
(upbeat music ends)